now it's time for you to think about a
product idea one you'll use throughout
the rest of this course yeah and if you
don't have an idea already think about
problems in your life that you want to
solve if nothing comes to mind
check out why common news requests for
startups in the instructor notes is
there an industry that you always think
about you can also observe others and
their work and talk to them about the
problems that they face or the problems
at their company's face the best
problems to address are those that you
have personal experiences with your
commitment to finding a solution will be
that much stronger and it'll be the one
thing that keeps you going through the
crazy highs and the crazy lows of
building a company it's a key idea to
make sure that through building
something that solves a real problem
yeah for example Apoorva Mehta the
founder of instacart and his co-founder
they spent a year and a half trying to
build a social network for lawyers
without realizing one cardinal truth
about the space and that's that lawyers
don't like to share a port that
eventually solved a different problem
and it was one that he thought was
always a personal pain grocery shopping
he realized that his friends were
willing to use the app that he built it
was unlike so many of his other products
by observing and reflecting on the world
around you you'll be likely to stumble
upon an idea that you love